the clothes recently laundered but
everything i'm wearing is at least
three years old keeping up appearances
but not planning
ahead wait a minute you can't make that
judgment from that evidence
he's got three-year-old clothes that are
washed because maybe he's a clean human
being
hey guys welcome back to the channel
been seeing a lot of videos where like a
lawyer will react to
movies about lawyers i've seen a lot of
doctors reacting to
doctor shows like house and comparing
and contrasting the realities
of the of the job with you know
fabrication with hollywood we all know
it's embellished to make it fun and
exciting i myself am a big fan of
sherlock holmes
uh but i'm gonna be honest me and the
boys are at the detective alliance the
internet detective alliance
are kind of sick of him paddling
horseshoe okay i mean i can't even tell
you guys how many times an old grandma
has come up to me asking me to find her
long-lost cat with only the power of
observation
and old fifi's yarn ball i mean sorry
grandpa old mittens
ain't coming back i hate to say it it's
time to move on
look the truth is the reality of being a
detective and what you see on you know
screen here it's very different look
this is what a real detective looks like
not someone
who hides behind the big screen i'm not
playing dress-up
unlike sherlock holmes okay so i'm gonna
run you guys through uh you know the
show
versus how it actually happens in
reality with
real clients real jobs and real cases
so where do we start uh well let's start
with the conclusion he comes to because
actually not only is this guy not
planning ahead apparently sherlock
realizes
something else three years ago is that
when they told you tell me what
you're a dead man walking so are you
you can't make that judgment call based
on the fact that someone has
three-year-old clothes you go you have
three-year-old clothes that must have
been when they told you you had cancer
terminal illness because you stopped
buying clothes
or you just happened to be wearing a
three-year-old piece of laundry that day
that's ridiculous
okay so this begins my first sort of
gripe
with the show i mean i know it's kind of
fun to think that
somebody with just like seeing the you
know the color of the thread of your
shirt
could all of a sudden figure out your
life story but there's such
little evidence and the leaps of logic
this guy makes
is a wild okay completely
ridiculous the shaving phone behind your
left ear
nobody's pointed it out to you traces of
where it's happened before so obviously
you live on your own there's nothing to
tell
you what shaving cream on your right ear
okay look maybe he just didn't clean up
that well today
right maybe he left the house late after
everyone else had already left
what is this ridiculous oh shaving cream
on your right ear
you clearly are a freak who lives alone
like
he could just kind of be a little
slovenly i don't know
it's just such a leap to make maybe he's
got a blind wife or something
there's a photograph of children the
children's mother's been cut out of the
picture if she died she'd still be there
photographs old but the frame's new you
think of your children you don't get to
see them
again okay so we see apparently he saw
this in the taxi cab
picture of two kids with a cutout and he
makes the assumption that this is his
wife
why couldn't it be their aunt who had a
giant pyramid scheme
and so they cut her out of the picture
it could just as easily be that
i just wish once during the show the guy
that he's talking to would be like
uh no wrong on all accounts actually i'm
doing fine
i'm a beautiful wife my kids love me
i'm not dying i'm actually just a
psychopath who likes to kill people
but of course we don't get that instead
he's right on all accounts
right and so then sherlock holmes is
gonna you know battle him
in this test of wits and he's gonna take
uh the pill bottle
okay did this brilliant detective
consider that it could have just been
the plotline of princess bride
like instead of it being a true 50 50
one of them's poison and the other's not
it could have just been
both of the bottles are poisoned
they were both poisoned i spent the last
few years building up an immunity to
iocaine powder
oh he's shot by john watson
okay i mean i hate to be the guy to do
this
but you don't shoot someone like this
one-handed how far is that shot oh it's
across
it's from one building to another
through glass
probably 50 40 50 yards uh
one-handed guys that's what you do it's
that's what you do this
train soldier anyway this i'm not
supposed to rant on watson but
you don't even get me started okay
stolen valor maybe i don't know i've
never seen
a trained military man go like this i
don't know why that wasn't the huge plot
hole there but
okay we'll move on then we move into the
first climax of the show
where someone is found dead in a hotel
room we're obviously looking at a
suicide
that does seem the only explanation of
all the facts wrong it's one possible
explanation of some of the facts you've
got a solution that you like but you're
choosing to ignore anything you see that
doesn't comply with it
wait a second isn't that what sherlock
holmes does though a lot
ignoring anything else that conflicts
with his
his idea his theories who's on the right
side of his head and vancouver's
left-handed
requires quite a bit of contortion
left-handed
i'm amazing didn't notice all you have
to do is look around this flap coffee
table on the left-hand side coffee mug
handle pointing to the left power
sockets habitually use the ones on the
left
pen and paper on the left-hand side of
the phone because he picked it up with
his right and took down messages with
his left you want me to go on
okay i know you guys are thinking to
yourselves hey
maybe he's got a point here that's kind
of an interesting thought okay
the problem with being a detective guys
uh
you know what it's full of challenges
but but the main problem
is that you're often dealt dealing in
probabilities you're never
sure of anything you don't know what's
true you're just trying to piece
together
evidence so when he's going like oh yeah
he definitely
was killed why oh he's definitely
left-handed there's always exceptions to
that and
actually conveniently i'm actually one
of those exceptions so
for example i'm ambidextrous i write
left-handed this is going to freak some
of y'all out because i don't know
that there are that many people who do
this too leave a comment below if you do
this too
but i write left-handed for example but
i bat right-handed and i like if i'd
pick up a coffee cup
i'd be right-handed so where he's
talking about like oh
the coffee mug is turned to the left so
he must be left-handed well i'm
left-handed when i write
but i pick the cup up with my right hand
so there's kind of stuff like that where
it's like
you're deciding a method of homicide
based on
such thin evidence that could be totally
wrong and instead of being like hey we
should consider this
he's like nope this is true and
i guarantee it your father's shocked
when his attacker came in
and the bullet went through the open
window oh come on
what are the chances of that wait you to
get the ballistics report
bullet in his brain wasn't far from his
gun i guarantee it yeah
again okay sure we'll believe that the
the bullet luckily went through the
window
but hey what are the chances that you
know he's not
left-handed he could have do some things
with his right hand or that sherlock
holmes is wrong about what
what handed he is no one's been in that
flat for at least three days
they've gone on holiday do you leave
your windows open when you go on holiday
breaking and is he about to break in
oh yep he's gonna climb through the
window
okay so i was with him until uh yeah
well i guess the good guy can just
commit misdemeanors and felonies at will
because yeah
i guess sherlock holmes is he's above
the law guys
[Applause]
sherlock somebody's been in here before
me
somebody broke an inner before me this
isn't fair
i want to be the first to be the first
person to break in here
but this other guy did before me okay so
right now john watson is locked out
and this guy now sees that uh you know
somebody's been in the thing okay so he
starts to look around for who
i think what he's about to do is the
dumbest thing in this show
cause let's say you're sherlock holmes
you're a detective and you think
there's a killer or some kind of you
know criminal
still inside maybe let in your sidekick
who can shoot people from 50 yards no
problem one-handed
that's a good idea you're unarmed you
need to have someone along who is
what does he do oh he's gonna look
around by himself that's right
and that's what you get that's what you
get for this honestly sherlock you
should have brought ola
one armed dead eye watson in here to
take care of the problem
you deserve all of this conveniently
this guy has sherlock holmes
a guy who's maybe seen him or knows this
this killer exists right so a loose end
what does this guy do
oh i better run i better leave this
uh eyewitness here
the number one detective who's gonna
catch me better leave him here
got him almost choked out but yeah let's
that's fine and of course eventually
this comes back to bite the bad guys
because
they are eventually caught by old
sherlock holmes
sherlock i can find anything about you
from your you know hair brush homes
so i hope you enjoyed this episode
it's a fun watch but honestly you know
if you want to
see what real detectives do you know um
this is not the place to find it it's
just a bunch of exaggeration it's
it's hollywood guys this isn't real life
like our show coffeezilla is very
different
you know this is a real profession um
that me and the boys and the internet
detective alliance go by and
this guy's been ruining it for so yeah i
did want to expose him a little bit
and also just share with you some laughs
i hope you enjoyed it if you did
leave a comment below like this video
let me know
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you